you're traveling to another dimension a  dimension not only inhabited by freaks  geeks but also a dwarf named Carlos a  journey to the gumdrop house on lollipop  Lane whose boundaries depend on your own  mental lambs that's a signpost up ahead  pay me what you owe me or kiss your legs  goodbye the Golden Age of  point-and-click adventures is back  a hilarious script written by terry  pratchett's Barbara's best friend's  neighbor  lots of unexpected plot twists and lots  of predictable ones to  several extravagant characters to annoy  mess with  nobody said but making it  easy but it's worth a shot  so are we done and what the hell is this  crap I didn't understand any of it is it  some kind of social metaphor I don't get  or did you hire shy Milan it's a  scriptwriter again by the way did  anybody watch Breaking Bad's finale man